Yeah,
you often hear from people who don't
live in New York City and having lived
in New York City that they couldn't live
in New York City because they're not
that kind of person.
That's always struck me as strange and
somewhat incomprehensible thing to say.
Being myself in New York City and
meeting everyday people who because they
live here must be that kind of person.
It's strange because taking together all
of them,
the web of their qualities and desires
and flaws,
I can't quite envision the types who are
left out.
The thing is I don't trust them.
I don't trust that they haven't confused
and idea of New York City for the real
thing and for that matter,
I don't trust that they haven't confused
and idea of themselves.
For the real New York,
it's conventionally thought is big and
loud and fast and drunk.
Edit is those things
man,
but New York can be as small as it is
big as quiet and slow as it is loud and
fast.
The city when viewed from within is
really a collection of peculiar
neighborhoods,
which is to say a collection of Charles
is my friend now,
this is Jerry.
Each has their own secrets.
Each has their own weird identities and
each has their own set of random
accumulated rules like when the horses
come out at 2:00
AM on Essex in the lower east side,
or when the wealthy folk go out to get
their brunch on Sunday mornings in the
upper west,
or how we all just assume that street
meat is perfectly safe because it tastes
so good.
Mustard,
please copious amounts of mustard
always,
always pagel.
These neighborhoods cohere around
equality common to all but by a kind of
the consignee and family resemblance by
a series of overlapping similarities
like the series of overlapping character
traits that give to it's eight point 2
million inhabitants,
a kindred bond and a bond that holds
fast in tragedy and paint.
For me,
what makes being in New York City
extraordinary is the feeling of standing
on the knife's edge of history.
What it must've felt like to be at Rome
during the caesars were at London in the
height of empire.
It's as if you're surfing the wave of
time and you can see what's coming and
you can see every expression of humanity
amplified and multiplied,
made stranger and more tolerant.
New York overwhelms you into a kind of
unceasing Oh,
and you could feel everything on every
corner all the time.
There are a lot of hedonists in New York
City and a lot of good people that it
may be the best place in the universe
anyway.
It's the best place in the universe to
get a drink at four in the morning.
Yep,
Yep.
Come in.